en el estadio en vez de allá donde se va
a disputar uno de los dos duelos
esperados de los octavos de final el
local camerún va a enfrentar a comoras
equipo debutante en una copa africana
que ya se metió entre los 16 mejores del
torneo en las horas previas en la
atención ha estado puesta en una
situación particular que ocurre con como
horas no tiene arqueros disponibles para
este encuentro dos de ellos se dieron
positivo por kobe 19 días atrás y el
tercero ben salim voy más se encuentra
lesionado en las últimas horas ali
ahamada uno de los arqueros que estaba
contagiado de kobe 19 se hizo una nueva
prueba en la que dio negativo y viajó de
garúa a yaundé para
ponerse a disposición de este encuentro
sin embargo la confederación africana de
fútbol no autorizó al jugador a entrar
al estadio siquiera para presenciar el
encuentro por lo que como horas salvo
que cambie la situación a último momento
tendrá que disputar este encuentro con
un jugador de campo ocupando la portería
por el lado camerún es mucho más alejado
de estancia de polémicas buscará
continuar con la buena forma que mostró
en la fase de grupos que lo llevó a ser
el primero en su zona y al erigirse como
uno de los candidatos sostenido también
en la localía y en el apoyo de su
público gran escenarios para un
encuentro de los octavos de final que
definirá a uno de los clasificados entre
los ocho mejores del torneo